willkommen zur aktuellen vorlesung heute
geht es zuerst darum die ontologie der
digitalität und zwar konkret um die
frage was ist virtuelle realität hier
sind jetzt sehr viele fremdwörter drin
ontologie digitalität habe ich schon mal
versucht zu erklären ich machen oben
rechts in youtube den link zu der
damaligen sitzung hinein wo es um die
klärung des verhältnisses ging heute
soll im zentrum die frage stehen was
macht eigentlich die existenzform
desjenigen aus was wir zur digitalität
zählen oder was die sphäre den raum der
digitalität betrifft also die frage nach
dem sein nach der existenz das ist die
unter logi und die frage was virtuelle
realität ist müssen natürlich genau noch
erklären hier muss vor allem der begriff
des virtuellen erklärt werden der
überhaupt nicht klar ist und auch der
begriff der realität muss geklärt werden
das soll im heutigen
getan werden und davor werde ich aber
noch mal eine rückblick geben auf die
letzte sitzung wo es um die app ist emol
ogi des internets ging dann geht es um
die virtuelle realität und dann gibt es
ein ausblick auf die nächste sitzung
ganz vorab möchte ich noch mal zur
struktur der vorlesung war sagen warum
nenne ich das ganze erst bis theologie
der digitalität und jetzt heute
ontologie der digitalität der
übernächsten sitzung werden wir es mit
der ethik der digitalität und dann
irgendwann später zum schluss noch mit
der ästhetik digitalität zu tun habe
warum halte ich mich da dieser
klassischen gliederung auf ich glaube
eben dass wir diese verschiedenen
bereiche der philosophie durchaus auch
auf die digitalität was auch immer jetzt
darunter zu verstehen ist übertragen
können ganz entscheidend wird aber die
frage der gelingenden anwendung dieser
philosophischen unterteilung davon
abhängen wie wir digitalität verstehen
und es gibt manche ansätze die versteht
digitalität ihr informations theoretisch
luciano flori die hatten in einer
sitzung behandelt heute komme ich auch
noch mal auf ihn zurück ich glaube dass
ein informations theoretischer zugriff
auf die digitalität zu schwach ist um
damit wirklich fungiert auch eine ethik
und eine ästhetik der digitalität zu
begründen ich glaube es ist der begriff
der virtuellen realität also das ist ein
schlüsselbegriff und nur auf basis
dieses begriffs der virtuellen realität
richtig verstanden so meine thesen
können wir auch eine ethik und eine
ästhetik der digitalität
auf einer soliden basis entwickeln jetzt
möchte ich noch mal etwas rückblickend
erklären nehme ich den begriff der inter
objektivität ich hatte ihn schon der
vorletzten sind so kurz angedeutet da
mache ich auch wieder oben rechts und
links rein was ist darunter zu verstehen
er ist mit dem begriff der trans
subjektivität verwandt den ich heute
auch noch mal genauer erklären möchte
damit ist folgendes gemein informationen
werden im rahmen der digitalität immer
unabhängig immer mehr unabhängig
unabhängiger vom subjekt und individuum
konkret bezogen auf das wissen bedeutet
dass das wissen wird zunehmend
kollaborativ also im zusammenhang von
mehreren subjekten und dynamisch im
internet realisiert und zwar so dass
eben das subjekt dahinter immer mehr
ideen immer mehr verschwindet also es
geht immer mehr um das wissen und
weniger darum wer es weiß ist also ein
kollaboratives unternehmen was dynamisch
ist mit dynamisch meine ich das wissen
ist nie statisch das ist anni ein
wissens bestand sondern alles ist im
internet was das wissen anbelangt im
fluss also das internet ist kein das
wissen im internet ist kein objekt
welches uns vorgesetzt wird wie zum
beispiel brockhaus damit können wir
wirklich erschlagen werden wenn wir da
die 20 bände im regal haben aber das ist
also ein da wird wissen er im sinne
eines objekts präsentiert im internet
ist das anders weil wir im internet
aktiv am wissen partizipieren allein
schon dadurch dass wir nach etwa weil
die suche im internet immer auch
rückwirkend das was als wissen
ausgewiesen wird anders formuliert das
wissen und das wissen wollen das
betrifft auch den begriff der
philosophie philosophie heißt ja nichts
anderes als die liebe zur weisheit man
kann es auch mit wissen wollen oder
erkennen wollen übersetzen wissen und
wissen wollen oder auch spuren sind im
internet aufs engste verschreckt warum
weil uns suchanfragen die wir durch
suchmaschinen ins internet einspeisen
wiederum auswirkungen darauf haben was
als wissen gilt oder was als besonders
wissenswert präsentiert wird die
künstliche intelligenz die auch im
internet zu grunde liegt die greift auf
informationen zurück in welche wir
selbst immer eingehen wir selbst sind
immer beteiligt an der datenbasis mit
denen die künstliche intelligenz
repariert zb eben durch suchanfragen
oder auch metadaten also wann wir etwas
tun also nicht genau was der inhalt der
suchanfrage ist oder sondern wann von wo
aus wir etwas gesucht haben dass sie die
wetterdaten die metadaten werden immer
wichtiger ist die unterscheidung
zwischen objekt ebene objekt datum und
metadaten
verflüssigt sich immer mehr und in
unseren suchanfragen die in die
datenbasis der künstlichen intelligenz
eingehen treten wir als individuen die
wir den suchbegriff eingegeben haben
immer mehr zurück und das meine ich mit
inter objektivität das ganze wird immer
mehr objektivität unsere suchanfragen
werden immer mehr von uns entfernt und
sie gehen irgendwie ein in die
datenbasis ist es aber überhaupt nicht
mehr rück zu verfolgen wie wir uns in
dieser datenbasis wer natur sich auch
immer sei wieder finden können ich gebe
jetzt ein paar beispiele die
per haben sie sicherlich schon mal
benutzt in meinen augen eines der besten
übersetzungsprogramme des internets die
firma wirbt damit besser als google und
alle anderen konkurrenz sein kann ein
objektives urteil fällen ich habe
jedenfalls gute erfahrungen gemacht die
per also hier ist eine verbindung
zwischen learning und wahrscheinlich
erste language de l greift auf linguee
zurück das ist eine gewaltige
übersetzungs datenbank im internet mit
einer milliarde übersetzungen und in
diese übersetzungen gehen wir selbst ein
warum weil sich diese datenbank speist
auf suchanfragen aber auch aus
publikationen oder internetforen
beiträgen also ganz verschiedene
datenstrukturen gehen ein mit diesen
daten zu tun aber auch wir selbst die
irgendwann mal spuren im internet und
wurde immer informations mäßig
hinterlassen haben also wir selbst
befinden uns da auch irgendwie drin wie
jedenfalls nicht als individuum dass man
sagt das ist jetzt peter müller und das
ist petra meyer die hat das gefragt das
ist nicht mehr von zentralem interesse
aber wir gehen irgendwie mittal aber das
heißt künstliche intelligenz operiert
nicht irgendwie mit irgendwas was uns
ganz fremd ist sondern wir sind daran
beteiligt und zwar nicht mehr auf
subjektive individuelle weise sollen auf
inter objektive weisen das ist das eine
was inter objektivität anbelangt als die
künstliche intelligenz in ihrer
operation dann darauf war es das letzte
zimmer zu sprechen kommt wikipedia und
das ist in meinen augen ein paradigma
für die erkenntnistheorie die app is
technologie der digitalität warum
erstmal sie kennen es alle dieses logo
untertitel ist auch interessant sich
anzuschauen die freie enzyklopädie
ja was heißt hier frei frei kann
zunächst einmal kostenlos ja is free for
free
kostet nichts dann kann aber auch frei
bedeuten die art und weise der
partizipation an diesem wissens bestand
der ist nämlich idealerweise bei
wikipedia auch frei das heißt jeder und
jede kann selbst autorin protour diese
gewaltigen enzyklopädie werden sofern er
oder sie sich an bestimmte regeln hält
die wiederum durch die gemeinschaft der
autorinnen autoren für wikipedia
kontrolliert werden auch bestimmt werden
im idealfall ich sag nur medial voll da
ist nicht alles perfekt handelt es sich
dabei also um ein demokratisches
unterfangen ein wissens bestand für alle
menschen kostenlos zur verfügung zu
stellen es ist erst mal eine ganz ganz
tolle sache ein paar daten noch zu
wickie peter möchte nachliefern über 55
millionen artikel stand 2020 also
ansprachen davon immerhin 2 5 millionen
deutschsprachige artikel in 310
sprachversionen sie haben es bestimmt
schon mal gesehen es gibt artikel auf
bayerisch auf friesisch in allen
möglichen dialekten das finde ich auch
eine tolle sache das heißt hier wird
sprache sehr ernst genommen und zwar in
jeder im gradierung in jeder stufe
berücksichtigt und nicht immer nur die
hochsprache also hier kann man auch
wirklich sprachlich interessante
entdeckungen machen so jetzt wollt ihr
noch auf einen punkt eingehen nämlich
auf die frage nach der kollaboration im
wissen ich hatte mal ein zitat gebracht
es gibt ein buch über wikipedia als ein
kollektives palim palim es bedeutet ja
antiken forschung dass man ein paar
büros hat wo immer wieder neue schicht
darüber geschrieben und die kann man
dann nur sehr schwer wieder sichtbar
machen bei wikipedia ist es ganz einfach
es gibt die version geschichte und jetzt
habe ich mir mal hier als beispiel aus
traurig aktuellem anlass kubik 19
genommen und wenn sie mal schauen das
ist die version geschichte also alle
versionen dies bisher zu diesem artikel
über cupid 19 wenn sie jetzt mal hier
schauen wie viele listen zeigen es gibt
es gibt also 500 seiten ist wenn sie
sich den aktuellen artikel anschauen
dann sehen sie das datum also ziemlich
aktuell dreiundzwanzigster november 2000
21 die autoren sind immer anonymisiert
das deutet auf gewisse objektivität hin
kann man auch wieder kritisieren die
lehrerinnen und lehrer verbieten aber
auch hochschullehrerin hochschullehrer
verbieten ihren studierenden häufig aus
wikipedia zu tieren zu zitieren darum
weil dahinter kein greifbarer autor
keine greifbare autorin steht muss man
diskutieren ich finde es aber was jetzt
die wissensgenerierung am gelang erst
mal positiv weil dadurch auch eine
gewisse sicherheit
gewährleistet ist und man die güte nicht
mehr mist an der person die dahinter
steht das verweist wieder auf inter
objektivität so jetzt schauen sie sich
mal die größe dieses aktuellen artikels
an 300
hier sehen sie immer im grünen die
veränderungen gegenüber der vorherigen
version das heißt hier ist ein bisschen
geschrumpft warum abkürzung korrigiert
doppelter link entfernen geschütztes
leerzeichen entfernen links optimiert
kein kleinkram also man muss immer jede
version kommentieren weil er etwas
entfernt wurde ist die version
geschrumpft und arbeit ist ja nicht
soweit nichts besonderes so aber das ist
jetzt nicht so sehr interessant springer
mal auf den aller ersten beitrag also
dem einmal 500 seiten listen zurück von
wann ist der kann man sich überlegen er
ist vom 14 januar 2020 zumindest die
deutschsprachige version wenn man jetzt
auf die englischsprachige geht was ich
übrigens auch sehr interessant findet
wissen auch unter verschiedenen sprach
gesellschaften sprach kulturen mal zu
beobachten ob es veränderungen gibt
sehen sie von 40 januar 2020 hier wieder
ein anonymus oder pseudonym vor vor der
sich dahinter verbirgt kommentar erste
anfang viel ist ja noch nicht bekannt
jetzt sind fast zwei jahre vergangen und
wir wissen doch einiges mehr über diese
erkrankung bei diesen virus hier also
ganz hoch interessant auch meinen diesen
version geschichten zu stöbern und zu
schauen was sich gegenüber der
vorherigen version geändert hat das ist
alles transparent das heißt wissen wird
hier fortgeschrieben und zwar in
echtzeit nicht wenn ihr neuauflage des
programms erscheint und in progress ist
häufig auch nicht ersichtlich war es
jetzt gegenüber den vorherigen version
geändert wurde in kritischen editionen
ist dass der fall neu aufladen hier
haben sie es wirklich zu greifen nahe
das heißt wikipedia kann man schon als
ein paradigma das wissen die piste
mologen internet darstellen warum ich
fasse zusammen weil es eben möglichst
objektiv ist sprich es gibt gewisse
regeln die dazu gehören jeder kann alles
sehen jeder kann eigentlich auch im
guten sinne alles beitragen ob es dann
bleibt ist eine andere frage und es ist
kostenlos sprechers unterliegt keinen
kommerziellen interessen das ist auch
noch ganz wichtig weil wir in der
letzten sitzung gesehen hatten das
internet wie ich finde leider die gründe
muss man genau bedenken doch starken
kommerziellen interessen ausgesetzt ist
auch was dann am ende die objektivität
bedingt also bei wikipedia haben wir
einen recht hohen grad an objektivität
ich sage nicht dass es perfekt ist aber
es könnte so eine art vorbild ein
paradigma für die gesamte entwicklung
des internet seien nämlich weg von der
kommerzialisierung hin zur inter
objektiven demokratisierung das möchte
ich noch einen weiteren punkt nennen wir
hatten schon gesehen das internet ist
was ganz besonderes
luciano florida spricht von einer
technologie dritter ordnung das heißt es
geht hier nicht um das verhältnis
zwischen technik und natur wie bei einer
axt sondern es geht um das verhältnis
der technik untereinander und zwar auf
eine weise die den bezug zur natur immer
mehr verliert das heißt die verhältnisse
der technologien konstituieren eine
eigene ordnung der technologische aspekt
tritt im internet immer weiter zurück
wir interessieren uns nicht mehr so sehr
wo da der dampf raus kommt und so wie
bei einer dampfmaschine sondern das
internet wird wahrgenommen als ein
virtueller handlungsraum indem wir
einerseits wissen erlangen an der zeit
auch wissen einspeisen und in dem wir
auch uns bewegen und den behandeln auf
eine ganz bestimmte logik die in einer
der nächsten sitzungen genauer gehandelt
werden muss wenn es um die ethik der
digitalität oder die ethik des internets
konkret geht und jetzt möchte ich
nochmal auf den begriff der trans
subjektivität ein kind run subjektivität
meint eigentlich nur die andere seite
der inter objektivität meint unsere
subjektivität uns individualität tritt
zurück gegenüber der objektiven struktur
des internets das bedeutet konkret wir
können unsere ideen gedanken meinung
gefühle die subjektiver natur sind in
das internet einspeisen und somit von
unserer trägerschaft unserer
subjektivität lösen wir können sie teile
als stichwort ist hier teil sie finden
immer bei jedem endgerät sei es ein
smartphone sei es eine apple watch sei
es ein webbrowser wasser immer immer
häufiger die option teilen ich glaube
dass das nicht nur ein komfortables
charakteristikum ist was ihnen irgendwie
die bedienung erleichtert sind dass
dahinter mehr steckt das teilen ist eine
grundstruktur die digitalität betrifft
weil wir hier subjektive gehalte vor
objektivieren in das internet übertragen
können und da liegen sie dann so vor
dass sie sogar auch den bezug zu uns
immer mehr verlieren und in die
dimension der inter objektivität gerückt
werden das kann zb ein daumen hoch seien
auf youtube das kann ein doji sein ein
lachender smiley ein weinendes miley das
ganze bekommt eine viel stärkere
objektive zeit listet immer mehr der
objektiviert ja und dann noch eine
andere tendenz des internets die die
transzendente tendenz gemeint habe das
bedeutet das internet hat in sich die
tendenz alle
abgekapselten netze internet sind
anzubinden also das netz macht vor
nichts halt es ist fast wie so ein
wurzelgeflecht was sich immer weiter
ausdehnt und alles versucht miteinander
in beziehung zu bringen das finde ich
eine ganz spannende situation weil sie
dann immer weniger differenz h das geht
auch wieder in richtung
interkonnektivität alles kann mit allem
in ein verhältnis gebracht werden die
privatheit gibt immer mehr zurück ich
komme aber gleich noch auf die
privatheit und das problem des darms zu
sprechen
das heißt das internet besitzt eine app
ist im system ische eigenlogik die vor
allem mit dem suchen nach informationen
zu tun hat jetzt kann man sagen gut
suchen musste ich doch auch früher in
bibliothek katalogen das ist sicherlich
richtig dann mussten sie auch als ein
gewisser wissens gestand da war denn
nicht mehr bis zu bewältigen ist weil er
nicht nur eine wand so unendlich viele
werden gefüllt wussten sie auch medien
oder zwischen hilfsmittel einschalten um
sich informationen zu besorgen der
unterschied ist jetzt dass meine der sie
suchen dann nicht nur nach titeln oder
nach autoren oder nach stichwörtern nach
schlagwörtern so war das nämlich bei
bibliotheken so ist es auch nur
suchmaschinen sondern sie suchen hier
nach wirklichen gehalten hat sie suchen
hier wirklich im wirklichen text und sie
suchen nicht nur nach texten die suche
nach bildern sie suchen nach allem
möglichen nachteilen sie können alle
möglichen arten von informationen suchen
und ihre suche selbst hat auch wiederum
einfluss darauf was dann am ende
gefunden wird also suchen und finden
sind immer mehr miteinander verbunden
aufgrund der algorithmischen verbindet
ja das heißt wir können uns jetzt die
frage nach der piste mission existenz im
internet stellen wie existieren wir im
internet werde ich gefunden also bin ich
kann man in abwandlung von bigelows
um fragen wie existieren im internet
existieren überhaupt wenn ich dort nicht
gefunden werde wenn ein suchanfrage
nichts bringt wir neigen immer mehr dazu
diesen schluss zu ziehen auch wenn der
problematisch heißt gedacht und die
frage nach der präsenz der existenz im
internet und jetzt möchte ihnen auch mal
hier auf die gefahr der blasenbildung
eingehen durch die künstliche
intelligenz im internet werden uns wenn
wir mal suchanfragen gestellt haben
immer häufiger ergebnisse gezeigt die
mit dieser suche zusammenhang das heißt
es bilden sich blasen die man auch als
ein paar annett bezeichnen kann das
heißt hier kommt es zu einer form von
abkapselung hier sind wir in einem
geschützten raum der nur noch das
beinhaltet was wir immer schon wissen
wollten der untersuchten denn verstärkt
und dadurch uns eben auch von anderen
optionen immer mehr entfernt und
objektivität und wissen beinhaltet ja
immer auch alternativ can select das
heißt das ist ein problem ein problem
was durch künstliche intelligenz
verstärkt wird ich glaube aber dass es
vor allem mit der kommerziellen
intelligenz zu tun hat die eben uns als
mögliche kundinnen und kunden immer mehr
in eine richtung treiben möchten suchen
wir nach etwas und dann bekommen wir
schon die nächsten anzeige das könnte
uns doch auch investieren nachdem wir
schon mal nach dem besucht haben das
scheint mir nicht ein prinzipielles
problem zu sein so nur ein problem was
an der kommerzialisierung des internets
von der künstlichen intelligenz hängt
daran möchte ich noch eine tendenz die
auch mit der abkapselung mancher netze
zu tun hat benennen nämlich die
subversion ich nenne es auch die
endnutzung das ist das darkness darknet
eine hoch komplexe sache sie können sich
mal den wikipedia-artikel dazu
durchschauen sie können mit bestimmten
suchmaschinen auch das durchsuchen von
google oder ähnlichen wird werden sie da
eben nichts angezeigt bekommt das heißt
dass dort hat die tendenz der subversion
der unterminierung dieser öffentlichen
struktur das internet es hat auch eine
tendenz der abkapselung und an tendenz
die eben nicht mehr der demokratische
den demokratischen prinzip genügt die
gelten eigene regeln ich habe es mir
auch ein bisschen verglichen wie wenn
hier eine gegen verfassung
konzipiert wird die eben gegen die
verfassung des internets als
grundsätzlich frei raum gerichtet ist
all das könnte man durchaus dann auch in
der sitzung über ethik der digitalität
nochmal genauer aus ethischer sicht
problematisieren es tage da werde ich
dann nochmal eine ausführlichere
einführung in dieses phänomen geben das
heißt das internet hat ein großes
problem wir haben es hier mit so vielen
informationen zu tun dass wir uns
zurechtfinden müssen mit hilfe von
bestimmten methoden die das wissen
handhabbar machen das heißt man muss
eine hermeneutik als eine wissenschaft
ist bestehens entwickelt die bezogen auf
das internet ist und diese hermeneutik
die muss vor allem mit der frage und
suchen und zu tun haben die muss weniger
zuzug zu tun haben mit dem direkten
wissen mit der direkten antwort sind
eher mit der frage wie wir geschickt
fragen formulieren die wir geschickt
suchen führt wieder zurück auf die
philosophie die philosophie hat auch
nicht so sehr mit dem wissen zu tun sind
vielmehr mit dem wissen wollen also mit
der geschickten frage die gute frage ist
die halbe anzahl und ähnlich scheint es
mir auch er mit dem internet zu sein
also im grunde genommen philosophieren
wir auf eine gewisse weise wenn wir das
internet befragen wenn man eine
suchmaschine bestimmte suchbegriffe
eingeben weil je besser diese formuliert
ist umso exakter oder interessante auch
das ergebnis ist wenn die suchmaschine
gut funktioniert wenn sie einen guten
algorithmus hat das heißt das internet
ist im idealfall ein repräsentatives
netz mit jal fall sage ich da können
alle nationen partizipieren keine nation
werden ausgesperrt aus ideologischen
gründen ich spreche hier von einem
idealzustand also jeder und jede darf
partizipieren und zwar auch durch
technische mittel durch
internetgeschwindigkeit das sollte mit
ja für alles gleich sein und so wird
dann das internet nicht nur zu einem
grundbedürfnis was man wieder im sinne
einer sucht charakterisieren könnte
deswegen finde ich grundbedürfnis nicht
nicht gut ausgedrückt internet ist kein
bedürfnis sind in ihrem grundrecht es
geht hier darum zu partizipieren an
einer weltweiten demokratischen struktur
jetzt können wir uns fragen brauchen wir
überhaupt eine demokratische internet
regierung da wäre ja eigentlich die
folgen oder ist das internet oder soll
das internet wesentlich anarchist ish
oder sogar noch kommerziell strukturiert
sein das ist eine frage die sich in
zukunft die philosophin und philosophen
nicht nur die aber eben auch stellen
müssen ich möchte ganz stark plädieren
hin zu einer demokratischen nutzung des
internets die natürlich auch
kommerzielle seiten hat wie auch unsere
lebenswirklichkeit auch geschäfte kennt
einkaufsmeilen aber die straßen usw
spricht die infrastruktur zum glück in
deutschland jedenfalls ist nicht so
stark kommerzialisiert das beginnt jetzt
mit einer autobahn-maut
zahlung und so weiter aber frisches
wasser usw man könnte es auch noch auf
wohnraum erweitern sollte in meinen
augen immer stark und kommerzialisiert
sein weil es eben eine konstrukteur ist
und ich glaube das selbe gilt auch für
das internet und in letzter konsequenz
wird dann vergleichbar mit den vereinten
nationen eine internet repräsentation
die eben auch für die stabilität die
objektivität im sinne der grundstruktur
jedenfalls und auch die finanzierung
rechnung treffen das ist dann aber ein
ausblick auf die eine plätzen sitzen wo
es um die politik der digitalität geht
da wird diese frage wieder stark im
zentrum stehen und jetzt kann man sich
natürlich noch frage ist das internet
eine lebensform geworden soziale friede
hatte betrifft das onlive geprägt finde
ich sehr überzeugend dann muss man aber
wenn man davon spricht dass es eine
onlive ist inbegriff der virtuelle
realität genau begründen und das findet
sich bei luciano wieso nicht erspart
diesen bereich der virtuellen realität
stark aus und hier müssen wir vor allem
auch in der heutigen sitzung nachliefern
anziehen und das führt mich jetzt auf
luciano flori die nämlich auf seine
onkologie der information florida nähert
sich wie schon gesagt hat über den
begriff der information der digitalität
verwendet den begriff der digitalität
nicht gespielt von der info sphäre
nochmal hier das cover seines buches die
vierte revolution nach verschiedenen
anderen revolution die kann man hier
nachlesen wie die info sphäre unser
leben verändert jetzt möchte ich ja zwei
zitate bringt erst mal passiert dass es
aus diesem buch was wirklich ist
informationen und was informationelle
ist wirklich viel kommt dieses zitat
vielleicht bekannt vor es ist in
anlehnung an hegels zitat was vernünftig
ist es dass es wirklich und was wirklich
ist das ist vernünftig
aus seiner rechtsphilosophie das knüpft
daran an jetzt sagte aber nicht was
vernünftig ist ist wirklich sind was
information l ist ist wirklich also
stellt sich die frage nach dem
verhältnis von informationen und
wirklichkeit also er versucht jetzt
wirklichkeit das ist die frage nach der
ontologie was existiert
über den begriff der information dazu
sehen doch mal ein zitat die infos viel
will have moved vom baitul fördert des
pace of information shootings in
animierten jetzt schreibt er hier bei
ihnen groß das führt jetzt ein bisschen
richtung heiliger der ja auch von seinen
spricht begrüßt oops i lon sogar noch
also die info sphäre die wird
synonym mit dem seien
grundsätzlich daran werden spricht
natürlich wieder an auf die information
ich möchte es ein bisschen
problematisieren ich glaube nicht dass
man das sagen kann ich glaube dass der
informations begriff viel zu schwach ist
um
wirklichkeiten ihren voll sind natürlich
stellt sich jetzt die frage was
wirklichkeit ist aber ich meine ihren
voll sind und dazu gehört eben auch eine
ethik also sprich die handlung zu fassen
in meinen augen ist der
informationsbedarf zu schwach um
handlungen erfassen zu können um die
realität von handlungen adäquat abbilden
zu können mir scheint flori die ist
immer noch zu stark es theologisch
erkenntnistheoretische orientiert als
dass er der ganzen realität in all ihren
facetten durch den informations begriff
gericht werden kann ich glaube dass wir
dazu den begriff der virtuellen realität
brauchen um auch eine ethik in ihrer
realität dann adäquat bestimmen zu
können und das wird mich jetzt zum thema
der heutigen sitzung nämlich virtuelle
realität und jetzt hatte ich mal eine
umfrage gemacht was assoziieren sie mit
wird stabilität und sie können jetzt mal
ganz kurz für sich überlegen im stillen
was sie mit virtuelle realität verbinden
das ihn mal zehn sekunden zeit bleiben
sie für sich und zeigt ihnen dann die
ergebnisse die meine teile aber den
teilnehmer damals
ausgegeben hatten
so die zehn sekunden soll zu langsam
herum sein wie es das ergebnis
möchten ein paar namen simulation ist
wird häufig genannt interessant auch
nicht echte realität ja hier virtuelle
realität brillen brillen
fake
technische probleme
künstlichkeit
als eigentlich ziemlich unklar nur was
irgendwie durchschimmert ist das
künstlich und das nicht echt das was
irgendwie im gegensatz zur realität
steht wenn das dann aber so ist ist ein
virtuelle realität ein widerspruch weil
wenn das virtuelle doch nicht echt ist
dann wäre doch eine nicht echte realität
in sich widersprüchlich also wie können
wir jetzt hier den begriff virtuelle
realität genau aufklären
ich möchte mich diese frage an werden
durch die neuen medien und dazu hier ein
neues buch vorstellen nämlich das
handbuch virtualität das finden sie als
studierende kostenlos auch in europa
können sich herunterladen ich möchte
dass daraus ein paar zitate bringen
erst mal und das wird auch in diesem
buch so deutlich ist virtuelle realität
nicht mit simulation zu verwechseln die
autoren schreiben diesem buch
virtualität hat im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert eine normalisierung in
zahlreichen gesellschaftlichen bereichen
erfahren war das virtuelle noch bis zum
ende des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts von
euphorischen bis apokalyptischen
reaktionen um den menschen im cyberspace
begleitet hat es inzwischen eingang
zahlreiche standardisierte praktiken
gefangen ein zitat das virtuelle ist
also nicht länger ein modell für einen
technischen eskapismus aus der
lebenswelt sondern sie eröffnet eine
kaum überschaubare fülle von szenarien
des einstiegs in und des anschlusses an
diese als andy lebens virtualität ist
teil unserer lebens das in der fülle
aller möglichen bezüge also virtualität
wird immer weniger als form der anti
realität oder chance wahrgenommen sind
als eine form von realität
immer mehr ein modus von realität ist
virtuell agilität und nicht mehr eine
form von realitätsverweigerung oder
realitätsflucht wenn man sich jetzt wird
realität also eine brille vorstellt dann
ist tatsächlich eine gewisse flucht man
lebt dann in einer illusionären welt wir
sehen aber und da bringt jetzt nur ein
paar beispiele das virtuelle realität
nicht in so einer brille aufgeht das
wird diesen begriff nicht gerecht ist
ein verkürztes verständnis noch ein
zitat stadt formen der isolation zu
befördern nämlich wenn man mit so einer
brille rumläuft dass die situation gehen
die virtuelle realität mit einer fülle
neuer und veränderte
interaktionsmöglichkeit und sozial form
einher das virtuelle wird auf diese
weise nicht nur zu einem resonanzraum
sozialer phänomene
es wird zum ort der konstruktion und der
aushandlung neuer sozialität und
umgangsformen sowohl von menschlichen
als auch von nicht menschlichen akteuren
das heißt es geht hier um das soziale
virtuelle realität schließt soziale
interaktion überhaupt nicht aus vielmehr
es ist eine form von sozialer
interaktion eine ganz besondere und hier
auch noch interessant auch nicht
menschliche akteurinnen sprich
künstliche intelligenz verstehe ich sie
ebenfalls können hier auch noch mit
einfließen in die virtuelle realität
noch ein letztes zitat virtualität
eröffnet abseits der fluchtmöglichkeiten
in eine totale und möglicherweise
totalitäre alte reed also dass andere
gegenwelt einen eigenen raum
verhandlungs erfindungen für
handhabungen von gegenständen
fingerfertigkeiten für interaktionen zu
sozialen wie auch ökonomischen austausch
ganz wichtig hier aus zogen es geht hier
um inter subjektivität vielleicht auch
inter objektivität jedenfalls verbindung
und gerade nicht um isolation oder
abdriften in eine scheinwelt ihr wieder
manfred spitze der kritiker trifft hier
glaube ich seine kritik nicht zu
jetzt muss man aber faire heitz halber
sagen dass virtuelle realität schon vor
dem aufkommen der neuen medien wie dem
internet oder wie irgendwelche
simulation da nämlich im falle von
banknoten geld ist ein typisches
phänomen virtuelle realität
geldscheine wenn sie bank note
betrachten die besitzen ihren wert nicht
aufgrund der materiellen basis dem
bedruckten papier dass es vielleicht
fünf cent wert sondern aufgrund einer
interaktiven gesellschaft die ihren wert
verbirgt hier haben wir wieder die
interaktivität oder die
gemeinschaftlichkeit die für virtuelle
realität zentral ist bank morgen
überlegen sie mal wie es ganz früher war
ganz ganz früher an den ursprung der
menschheit da hat man naturalien
gedanken schneider gab es dann apfel
gegen eine karotte
da war das ganze entsprechend nicht
virtuell
vielleicht sogar schon ein bisschen
virtuell die frage ist lässt sich
überhaupt menschliche interaktion ohne
virtualität dem ich möchte sogar
bezweifelt aber alles materialien
tauscht gab entsprechenden war noch
nicht so stark virtualität gespielt
virtualität kam dann ein spiel als man
sich geeinigt hat dass diese muschel
jetzt eben zehn äpfeln entspricht
ungefähr werden oder das gold aufgrund
seiner
seltenheit eine gewisse funktion eines
wertes übernehmen das verdankt sich aber
letztendlich gold natürlich auch seiner
physikalischen eigenschaften und seiner
beschränktheit im sinne von banknoten
wird das noch viel unabhängiger von dem
material basis wie es zb auch beim golf
als das heißt der wert den banknoten
haben der ist virtuell der ist
garantiert durch eine konvention durch
in der subjektivität aber nicht durch
die materielle basis nicht durch das
papier auch wenn es noch so viele
silberstreifen drin hat das macht den
wert nicht ausleihen es dient nur dazu
falsches geld auszuschließen also sprich
simuliertes geld von virtuellem geld zu
unterscheiden sie sehen hier bekommt
geld und virtuelle realität einen engen
bezug und sie sehen auch die kausalität
die davon ausgeht mit einer banknote die
eine virtuelle realität ist können sie
sich was kaufen das ist keine simulation
da machen sie wirklich ganzen
partizipieren an der lebenswelt also
sprich beispiel der banknote sehen sie
das virtuelle realität nichts mit
simulation oder illusion zu tun hat
dennoch aber etwas mit einer kreativität
und mit einer alternativen realisierungs
weise wie sie es eben physisch machen
könnten wenn sie naturalien
gegeneinander auszahlen das heißt das
virtuelle ist dass inter subjektiv
kreative
korrespondierend geeinigt prinzip dass
banknoten den wert verleiht damit geht
aber einher dass die digitalisierung die
jetzt hier vor allem mit virtuelle
realität in verbindung gebracht werden
soll die virtuelle realität des geldes
weiter flexibilisiert weil sie
irgendwann nicht mehr die banknote
brauchen das papier brauchen das diesen
wert dann durch subjektivität in der
subjektivität garantiert sondern sie
können digitale währung entwickeln
bitcoin sogar aufgrund von algorithmen
wie bitte oder online-banking da haben
sie gar keine materielle basis mehr wie
es bei einem einer bank gefahren das
sicherlich bei onlinebanking haben sie
irgendwelche rechner stehen server aber
die sind nicht mehr auf derselben ebene
zu sehen wie die banken und der wert das
heißt hier geht es um wirklich völlig
körperlose entitäten die dennoch einen
werther und kausal wirksam sind digitale
währung sind kein hirngespinst auch
werden sie ihre gesellschaft wie man es
bei bitkom sieht das heißt irgendwie ist
es uns nicht so ganz geheuer auch online
banking ist vier nicht ganz geheuer
warum weil ich da nichts in der hand hat
und trotzdem soll ich da einen wert
haben auf der geldkarte ist es ja auch
nicht drauf es ist irgendwie nirgends
aber doch da und genau das bezeichnet
virtualität
das heißt virtuelle realität bedeutet
eine andere realisierungs weise bereits
bestehende phänomene sie können den wert
eines naturalien natürlich gegebenen
gutes wäre es apfel den können sie auf
eine andere weise realisieren
durch geld und sie können das dann nicht
noch weiter virtualisieren dh hier geht
es um begibt virtualisierung als
alternative realisieren indem sie zb
eine banknote virtualisieren zu einer
online wer der abstrahieren sie indem
sie virtualisieren von der materiellen
basis von dem papier und sie haben eine
weitere virtualisierungs leistung
vollbracht weiteres beispiel ist das
universitäts das bislang bis vor kurzem
noch in den räumlichkeiten der
universität stattfinden sollte und wenn
sie das virtualisieren dann machen sie
daraus ein virtuelles digitales seminar
mit libyens gerade eben machen sie
können das auf youtube stellen sie haben
viel mehr möglichkeiten das heißt durch
die virtualisierung lösen sie sich
zunehmend von der ursprünglichen
struktur wie es nicht man physisch
gebunden ist universität senate und
erhalten viele weitere möglichkeiten die
sie auf die ursprüngliche art und weise
nicht handeln sich natürlich auch andere
probleme ein aber es handelt sich bei
virtuellen lehre nicht um der simulation
von gier und das was sie gerade erleben
ist realität hier wird findet gerade
statt und es wird auch von einem
universitäts ordnung anerkannt und es
wird immer mehr anerkannt werden müssen
auch wenn früher die tendenz da war das
als spielerei abzutun die jetzt in der
not sieht man weiteres beispiel ist
bücherei sie haben hier eine durch reihe
mit vielen büchern physischen exemplaren
regal und sie können das virtualisieren
indem sie digitale bücher von server
stellen die man sich ausleihen kann und
zurückgeben kann nach einer bestimmten
zeit dann virtualisieren sie auch den
rückgabe
vorgesehen aber es verändert sich vieles
weil dasselbe exemplar könnte
prinzipiell von tausenden nutzern
gleichzeitig entliehen werden macht man
jetzt nicht man beschränkt das künstlich
aber die digitalisierung würde es
ermöglichen dass das serie exemplar des
buches von tausenden nutzern nutzen zur
selben zeit endlich was bei einem
physischen excel band nicht geht sie
sehen hier ändern sich einige dinge
bezüglich dem raum und der zeit
wir gehen im nächsten sitzung auf die
raum und zeit logik diese virtuellen
realität ein wie man schöne beispiele
virtuelle bücherei sieht noch ein
beispiel universal lexikon ich bin zu
beginn der heutigen sitzung darauf
eingegangen brockhaus soundsoviel bände
20.30 binde können sie virtualisieren
auf eine ganz interessante weise durch
wikipedia
ich habe dann noch ein fragezeichen
dahinter gemacht deswegen weil wikipedia
einfach noch nicht so zitierfähig ist
und vielleicht auch gar kein brockhaus
seien nicht also die entsprechung gilt
nicht man kann natürlich universal
lexikon auch in anderen sie nicht
verstehen so dass da alle mitarbeiten
können das ist einfach eine sehr breite
basis hat dann wiederum der wikipedia
eine hoch spannende form der
virtualisierung die zugleich viele neue
optionen eröffnet wie eben die version
geschichte die ihm zu beginn der
heutigen vorlesen demonstriert haben uns
einige beispiele zum schluss noch ein
weiteres beispiel der virtualisierung
nämlich fernsehen her das gute alte
fernsehen wird immer mehr in den
hintergrund gedrängt auf basis von neuen
entwicklungen wie youtube zb auch hier
youtube hat eine gewisse analogie zur
wikipedia
warum sie können selbst auch auf youtube
medien einstellen das heißt die
entwicklung geht weg von der bloßen
rezeption dass sie wissen nur
konsumieren hin zu aktiven
wissensgenerierung wissen wird ein
dynamisches geschehen die unterscheidung
zwischen nutzerin oder rezipienten und
produzentin fällt immer weiter weg die
beiden trennungen sind so nicht mehr
haltbar
im bereich der neuen medien die in
meinen augen eine form von virtueller
realität sind
so das heißt wir müssen jetzt
zusammengefasst jetzt mal auf den
begriff gebracht philosophisch
analysiert wir müssen virtuelle realität
von simulationen von fiktion und von
illusion strengen unterscheiden denken
sie zurück an die banknote die banknote
ist eine virtuelle realität noch
extremer das online guthaben ist eine
virtuelle realität das ist nicht nur das
ist keine simulation
hier wird nicht geld im sinne einer
spielgeld simuliert nein damit können
sie wirklich was kaufen es ist keine
fiktion
sie bilden sich nicht ein eine
besitz zu haben nein das geld ist
wirklich da und es ist eben auch keine
illusion nein das ist realität sie
können sich damit was kaufen wird
anerkannt dass virtuelle realität ist
lebenswirklichkeit saal wirksam und
objektiv sie können ein online konto
umwandeln in eine banknote sie können
ihren betrag von 1.000 euro auf dem
konto umwandeln in eine 1000 euro
banknote und die können sie umwandeln in
soundsoviel naturalien manchmal kriegen
ist es billiger manchmal teurer aber sie
können alles im lande umsätzen virtuelle
realitäten lassen sich über führen in
physische realität zumindest im falle
des geldes heißt das hochgradig flexibel
sie sind da sehr frei mit virtuellen
realität sie werden unabhängig von
bestimmten physischen gegeben dennoch
obwohl virtuelle realität nicht derselbe
wie simulation fiktion oder illusion
sind erhalten virtuelle realitäten
momente von simulationen und fiktion
warum virtuelle realität ist ein
kreatives phänomen das heißt und dem sie
virtualisierten dem sie sich von dem
physischen original unabhängig machen
wollen müssen sie eine ihre kreativität
anstrengen müssen sie erstmal eine form
von simulationen pickeln dh der lehre
kann man das schön sehen er ist man
versucht man die digitale lehre eins zu
eins zu modellieren also dass die
physische lehre eins zu eins digital
abzubilden das ist die simulation dann
merkt man ganz plötzlich
und dann kommt der fiktionale aspekten
spielt dann überlegen sie mal wie könnte
es anders sein dann denkt sie an die
möglichkeiten was geht denn zumindest im
physischen nicht dann sind sie hier in
dem bereich der möglichkeiten es geht es
um die fiktion aber in der fiktion
bleibt es auch nicht weil es wird ja
wirklich das heißt man könnte sagen
virtuelle realitäten sind so eine these
aus simulationen und fiktion sie es
werden fusioniert zu einer realität und
deswegen ist virtuelle realität ein
hochgradig kreatives phänomen die
menschen die geld erfunden haben die
kulturen die papiergeld oder was auch
immer erfunden haben unsere vorfahren
waren hochgradig kreativ hochgradig
und in dem man eben dann unabhängig von
physischen vorgaben konstituiert
virtuelle realität eine anthologie der
freiheit das heißt hier geht es immer um
freiheit freiheit von die freiheit von
der physischen vorgegebenen welt wird
relativ unabhängig davon und sie werden
frei zu anderen dingen sie werden
nämlich viel flexibler also positiv und
negative freiheit sind in der virtuellen
realität zu finden und das ganze führt
jetzt so eine übersicht das heißt sie
sollten
realität und ihre realität unterscheiden
und das virtuelle als eine form von
realität fassen wie auch das mental in
form von realität ist unsere gedanken
sind ja auch nicht nur illusion und das
physikalische physische ist in der regel
das was man gemeinhin und der realität
versteht wenn die grundschüler kleine
kinder fragen was ist real was ist
wirklich dann wird nicht sagen jaja das
glas was ich anfassen kann wenn sie dann
fragen ja und der wind in die luft die
kann man doch nicht anfassen dann fängt
schon an der iss ist die luft schon noch
ein real und und dann irgendwann mit den
gedanken der gedanke dass ich jetzt hier
bin ist er auch real und wie sieht's aus
mit der banknote wenn sie ein kind ein
geldschein zeigen und von 1000 euro und
daneben ein spielzeugauto und dann das
kind fragen ja was hat jetzt mehr wert
dann wird es sagen das spielzeug aus
oder die puppe es heißt hier sehen sie
hier gibt es einen übergang virtuelle
realität ist eine sehr anspruchsvolle
kognitiv voraussetzung scrollen realität
die realität hingegen würde ich sagen
ist die fiktion die simulation die
illusion das heißt jetzt nicht dass es
hier nicht noch andere form gibt man
kann sich zum beispiel belegen auch
zahlen existieren ideelle gegenstände
wenn man klar thonicke rinn und
platonischer ist die zahl 5 oder die
idee des baumes das wäre auch noch eine
möglichkeit hier unter realität zu
fassen möchte jetzt aber nicht
erschöpfen das ganze handeln mit geht es
nur darum dass virtuelle ist eine form
oder eine bestimmung der realität und
ist zu unterscheiden von simulationen
fiktion als form der realität
jetzt kann man sich fragen wie verhält
sich virtuelle zur physischen oder
physikalischen realität
er hat ein neuer autor eine these
formuliert ihr vorlesen möchte der
virtual does not constitute or tonnes
independent or close system padis
instead of ways dependent in der idea of
wales und die app world with the witches
im bett der aufsatz ist auch betitelt
gegen die autonomie oder die neue
autonomie der virtualität der autor
spricht von anderen nun also nicht
autonomie der wirtschaft realität ja wie
ist das jetzt zu sehen also auf der
einen seite muss man ihm recht geben
virtuelle realität hängt immer mit
unserer lebenswelt zusammen das hatten
wir aber auch schon diesem handbuch
virtualität gesehen die autorinnen
autoren hatten gesagt virtualität ist
ein lebens wirkliches phänomen das heißt
die virtuelle realität hängt mit der
physischen realität insofern zusammen
als sie auf ihr reagiert also sie wird
erst möglich dadurch dass es eine
physische lebensweltliche grundlage gibt
zum beispiel haben wir ein papier
geldschein auf dem er giert dann der
wert den man ihm
zuschreibt oder wenn sie von computern
und sonstigen dingen ausgehen dann so
reagiert eben auch ein online wert auf
physikalischen realität der
rechnerarchitektur dies bedeutet
freilich nicht dass die virtuelle
realität nur auf der physischen realität
oder auf einer bestimmten physische
qualität energien kann regieren heißt
die darauf bestehen sondern es lassen
sich auch andere szenarien denken in
welcher die selbe virtuelle realität auf
eine andere materielle basis emittiert
was man eben die multiple
realisierbarkeit des virtuellen man kann
sie können geldwerte auf ganz
verschiedene materielle weise erzeugen
sie können gilt im agieren lassen auf
geldscheinen sie können es im agieren
lassen auf muscheln auf anderen dingen
das heißt hier ist sehr flexibel
ja das heißt erst wenn wir den begriff
der virtuellen realität mit blick auf
die begriffe der möglichkeit der
wirklichkeit der fiktion der simulation
und der illusion geklärt haben können
wir fundierte aussagen treffen auch über
eine ethik und mehr eine didaktik und
eine ästhetik und eine politik der
digitalität daran hängt an diesen
begriffen die müssen ja an die richtige
ordnung bringen ich habe einen vorschlag
gemacht wie man virtuelle realität
jenseits dieser bloßen auffassung als
fiktion und simulation isolation
illusion verstehen kann ganz wichtig ist
immer die möglichkeit spricht wie ich
schon mal sagte virtualisierung ist eine
alternative
realisierung und diese alternative thet
ist durch den bfd möglichkeit angezeigt
und die kreativität die ich sagte mit
virtuelle realität zu tun hat die hängt
auch in dieser möglichkeit zu sagen wir
machen uns frei von bestimmten vorgaben
wie das am beispiel des geldes gesehen
haben soll jetzt möchte ich noch einen
kurzen ausblick geben auf die ontologie
der digitalität auf die an der nächsten
sitzung genauer eingehen werde mich auf
ihre raum zeitliche struktur virtuelle
realitäten sind raum zeitlich unabhängig
oder unabhängiger von ihren materiellen
vorbilder nehmen wir als beispiel den
apfel er hat den apfel habe ich als
einen wertgegenstand nach ein paar tagen
wenn ich ihn nicht richtig lagere wird
av liegt am verliert er sein wert das
ist jetzt mit dem geldschein nicht so
unmittelbar wenn ich den zwischen andere
äpfel läge dann diesen faulig dann hält
das noch durch aber wenn er ein bisschen
nass wird und dann aufweicht und dann
zerfällt dann verliert erscheint auch
sein werden anders ist es mit
online-konten da sind sie ziemlich
unabhängig kann es natürlich auch
irgendwelche probleme gegeben dass ich
gehackt werde das hängt jetzt aber mit
anderen punkt zusammen auch wenn da die
rechner architektur dem dienst versagt
ist das geld trotzdem noch da aber auch
hier kann man sich fragen wann der wert
verloren geht jedenfalls steht fest sie
werden immer unabhängiger vom apfel hin
zur bank währung von physischen
umständen von wetterbedingungen und sein
stimmte zu werden unabhängig von der
materialität
beispiels auch noch das physisch
gebundene klassenzimmer versus das
virtuelle klassenzimmer
corona kann kommen wir können hier
virtuelle lehre machen weil wir uns
nicht physisch begegnen müssen ich
stecke sie nicht an wenn ich ihnen hier
direkt virtuell ins gesicht reden hat er
hat er was gutes virtuelle realitäten
folgen keiner sukzessive zeitlose diesen
ausblick auf die nächste sitzung also
eins nach dem anderen soll ihre
gegenstände sind ubiquitär präsenz man
könnte auch eine präsenz dafür einführen
die ordnung der virtuellen realität
ist nächstes sehr sukzessiv zeitlich zu
verstehen sondern logisch vernetzt
darauf gehe ich aber der nächsten
sitzung genau noch ein und was auch noch
wichtig ist virtuelle gegenstände sind
durch eine super leitfähigkeit und
reibungsloses kite dem begriff flow
really geprägt verbunden die sich der
digitalen technik verdanken durch
digitale technik können sie vielleicht
ihre informationen austauschen
informationen unterliegen nicht mehr
eine reibung wegen einer materiellen
basis wie es zb bei büchern der fall ist
sondern die information kleid
dementsprechend auch unsere handlung und
realitäten das ist eine ganz andere
bewegungsdynamik da die eben auch mit
der digitalisierung und der raumzeit
logik zu verstehen ist und um dieses
thema soll es eben der nächsten sitzung
gehen da steht der ubiquitäre
präsentismus im zentrum wie ich in meine
alte überall das über all das ist hier
das räumliche der digitalität überall
dateien virtuelle realitäten global sein
und der präsentismus bedeutet ist immer
zugleich da das scheint mir ein zug dass
der digitalität sie seien darauf geben
mit einer nächsten sitzung mehr ein
jetzt bedanke mich für die
aufmerksamkeit und bin gespannt auf die
diskussion